the holidays with the best of Las Vegas
Dom DeMarco's Pizzeria and bar the
sponsors of this segment recently took
home the gold for best pizza outdoor
dining and Chicken Wings Plus the silver
for catering Rocky stopped by to show us
why
[Music]
we celebrated our 11th anniversary on
Thursday December 1st we had the happy
hour from open to close and we had such
a great turnout we were mobbed from the
minute we opened to the minute we closed
and I want to thank all our Royal loyal
customers and all the new customers and
new friends we made and what has kept
those customers so loyal over the years
the food and the fun we're known
actually worldwide for our pizza we're a
family with the Pharaoh pizza out of
Brooklyn
and that's our number one seller here is
pizza and then salads pasta wings and
we're very well known for our happy hour
we have a great Happy Hour Monday to
Friday from two to six
and from two to four we have what we
call the happiest hour where every Pizza
in the place and every bottle of wine is
50 off if you look back here you can see
all the things that we went through to
years
uh best gold for best pizza the happy
hour outdoor dining and catering and
even Channel 8 can vouch for that this
past year Channel 8 had the pizza
bracket similar to the college
basketball brackets where they picked 64
of the best pizzerias in town and people
called in and voted and and we won that
we came in number one we really
appreciate it because we worked really
hard at what we do and when we try to do
our best now let's Circle back to the
award-winning out door dining in k do we
do a lot of catering we do in-home
in-house catering we'll come to your
house we'll set everything up but we
have a beautiful patio and we do a lot
of parties on the on a patio in fact
between now and Christmas almost every
day we have a party we have two patios
an upper and a lower and we just love it
out there and it's a fun time this is
our beautiful upper patio great and
seats 42 comfortably and it seems like
between Thanksgiving and Christmas thank
God we're booked every day and every
night and here you could see this is our
the ferris special pizza and uh
here's a penny vodka dish that Alex made
up and uh
it's a very popular place I wore the
wrong color for Italian today the pizza
here is worth the risk of red sauce on
the white shirt they do all kinds of
parties on this deck birthdays companies
and even weddings I love the fireplace
it's a great it's a Vibe you hit the
nail on the head Rocky it's a great Vibe
you've got some deep history family
rooms here in this food let's talk about
where the recipes come from okay as I go
ahead I like to talk about that we'll
talk about the pizza first because
pizza's in our name let's do it the
pizza recipes all come from a guy named
Dom Demarco
who was he passed away about three
months ago but he was the Pizza King wow
and he his place in Brooklyn was called
beefara pizza and we also have a place
in Caesar's Palace called the Pharaoh
Pizza which is all the same recipes as
here so all the pizza recipes are exact
are done Demarcus I worked with them for
three years on Avenue J and East 15th
Street in Brooklyn and I brought these
pizza recipes here now the pasta recipes
are all the family recipes the meatballs
are my mother's recipe to sauces my
mother's and it's all some of my aunts
some of my uncles but we all love food
here that's the thing about this right
we think our food is fantastic and the
people seem to agree with us so we're
very happy about that well you're
keeping the Marcos Legacy alive here
thank you to Don DeMarco's Pizzeria and
bar for sponsoring this segment give
them a call at
702-570-7000 or visit
domdemarcos.com for more information you
can also check out their weekday happy
hour from 2 to 6 pm